l' affaire grégory christine villemin ne
sera pas jugée dans les vosges mais à
dijon en côte-d'or peut-être aux assises
de cette ville ainsi en a décidé la cour
de cassation aujourd'hui un nouvel
épisode dans cette ténébreuse affaire
paul lefèvre après trois heures de
délibéré la chambre criminelle de la
cour de cassation a rendu son arrêt à
retenir trois choses d'abord
l'annulation de trois éléments de
l'accusation important pour certains
mais non essentiels pour au dossier
ensuite la désignation de la chambre
d'accusation de dijon pour compléter la
procédure enfin et c'est la surprise la
désignation de la cour d'assises de
dijon pour et christine villemin je vous
rappelle au départ les avocats de
christine villemin avait présenté à la
cour de cassation dit moyens
d'annulation dont plusieurs concernés le
rapport d'autopsié du corps de l'enfant
l'annulation de ce rapport d'autopsié
aurait signifié en réalité la fin sans
procès de l' affaire villemin la cour de
cassation a maintenu cette pièce
essentielle du dossier mais un suivi
l'avocat général françois rabut qui
demandait que christine villemin ne soit
pas jugé à epinal afin d'éviter les
passions de cette affaire qui n'est dit
il est un gâchis de justice